ganz wichtig von einem youtube profi wie
mir wenn das video auch mal zehn minuten
geht dann könnt ihr so oft sehr bald
einschalten wie ihr wollt dann könnt ihr
sogar 15 mal werbung schalten und das
spielt euch natürlich richtig gut in die
kassen und etwas gedacht und jetzt
bekommen
bei hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen
bayern ein video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut und zwar heute mit
einem video was viele vor allem die
jüngeren von euch die vielleicht selber
youtube machen habe ich sehr oft gefragt
haben ich habe eine zeitlang sehr viele
nachrichten bekommen herrlich kannst du
dir nicht auch mal mein video anschauen
ich bin gerade mal sechs jahre alt
machte aber schon youtube videos haben
sich glaube das war wirklich 6 und zwar
geht es heute wieder um die jüngere
youtube generation ja wenn ich
irgendwann mal kein bock mehr auf
youtube weil ich 30 bin kann ja
vorkommen gibt es ja die neue generation
falls es da nicht irgendwas anderes als
youtube gibt aber wir machen heute hier
in der neuen part ich habe mir ein paar
von euch rausgesucht hier konnten wir
auf instagram kanäle schicken und viele
haben sich beworben und ich bin echt mal
gespannt sonst war ich will hier drei
leute ausgesucht wir haben hier einmal
jesse und lara hat mir glaube ich eine
freundin von den beiden geschrieben hat
ich kann das jemand was raussuchen meine
iwf und ihre freundinnen sind beide 12
also meine internet beste freundin heißt
glaube ich iwf oder so ich weiß es
klingt auf jeden fall logisch dann haben
wir hier
german der deutsche
so bin ich auch mal gespannt und wir
haben hier schlau gefragt sie ist auch
noch jünger glaube ich habe jetzt noch
nicht reingeschaut aber ich glaube so
höchstens 13 oder so vielleicht auch 14
keine ahnung ich würde sagen geladen gar
nicht lange und fangen einfach mal hier
bei schlau gefragt an ist natürlich ganz
klar alle kanäle sind gema unten in der
video beschreibung verlinkt und ihr
könnt ja nach dem video in die
kommentare schreiben welcher kanal euch
von den ganzen am besten gefällt ich
schau dir einfach mal das beliebteste
video an würde ich sagen und das wäre
tausch paket mit sydney schlau gefragt
heute bin ich nicht als paket mal ganz
wichtig dass auch dass man eine adresse
das hatte ich schon so auf dass meine
adresse in meinen videos drin war
aber kann man somit nichts lesen sie in
sydney sid auf jeden fall auch noch
länger aus ich würde sagen wir es gibt
einfach mal so hier auf minute neuen
relativ in die mitte gut ich könnte mir
hier jetzt ziemlich lange dieses tauschs
paket video anschauen aber ich will mal
was sehen wo sich vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr geschnitten hat oder sowas
auch ein bisschen kürzer ist was man
sich mal kurz rein ziehen kann was das
denn ihr ford mustang gt au den habe ich
also nicht den gta bauen musste was
macht ihr denn hier
das hätte ich als da muss ich sagen das
hätte jetzt will ich überhaupt nicht
erwartet alter von vier bis dahin war
oder was
das finde ich eigentlich richtig
[Musik]
ich geb dir sofort schon man doch nach
oben also ich fahre jetzt zwar nicht
mehr diese muss also ich bin schon froh
dass ich den mustang von 2017 habe weil
dieser jetzt zum beispiel der sieht mir
irgendwie ein bisschen zu böse aus aber
ich finde es richtig cool jetzt ist ein
video machst also ich habe doch nach
oben gegeben und eine szene noch ist das
jetzt dein auto davon ein eltern sodass
wir ja echt cool
wir schauen mal kurz vielleicht steht
regen auf ihrem kanal wie alt sie ist
vielleicht auf instagram also wie alt
sie ist kann ich gar nicht wirklich
sagen ich will einfach mal schätzen
maximal 14 es ist natürlich immer sehr
schade wenn man sich verschätzt aber vom
aussehen her würde ich jetzt sagen 13 13
jahre 14 jahren also cooler kanal sehr
bunt gemischt wer bock hat auf auto
videos schul videos und auch musical i
videos sehe ich hier glaube ich
schaut mal vorbei und machen weiter mit
dem nächsten kanal und zwar ist das
german der hat glaube ich irgendwann mal
ein video von mir kommentiert dass er
gerne in dieses format rein möchte was
geht hast du geschafft ich hoffe du
freust dich und wir schauen uns mal ein
video von dir an ach so was ich jetzt
gerade bei der schlau gefragt gar nicht
gesagt hat vielleicht irgendwelche
verbesserungs tipps oder so an sich ist
das was man 13 macht oder sonnen video
auf die beine zu stellen wir ein auto
vorstellen natürlich schon echt richtig
gut und da jetzt zu sagen das kann man
noch besser machen und das kann man noch
besser machen ich finde da sollte man
gar nicht drauf rummeckern das kommt
eigentlich von alleine so die kamera
qualität weil es nicht die beste auch
der sound war jetzt nicht so aber das
war bei mir früher genauso deswegen
mache einfach so weiter das entwickelt
sich und mich als unterhalten so und
darum geht es ja so auch hier schauen
wir einfach mal das beliebteste video
interface karten meinen hals los da
kommt die ganze zeit so kohlensäure vom
red bull burg 150 oder hierfür ein
aktbild von mir gut wir schauen einfach
mal hier am see kartfahren darum ist
jetzt ne macke habe ich die
[Musik]
laut
ein kleiner
ok ich schaue mal kurz wie alt er ist
vielleicht dass wir drin ich würde auch
noch so schätzen 14 steht auch nicht
dabei irgendwie komisch aber wir gehen
einfach mal ja ich bin viel zu sagen
ich sehe also kamera qualität ist voll
okay ich denke mal dass mir da keinen
aufgenommen ist ein bisschen hell aber
gut das muss man jetzt nicht es gibt
einfach mal ein bisschen bis hierhin
ich schaue mir einfach noch mal hier im
vergleich die fußball challenge an gegen
sein also vom schnitt her fand ich das
gut von der musik her auch war nicht zu
laut
wo nicht schlecht bezeichnen das geht
also sein bruder ist auch gar nicht mal
so schlecht der ist acht jahre alt kann
aber schon richtig gut ich weiß nicht
der kommt schnell auf den punkt nicht so
wie ich kann gut mit einer kamera
sprechen also dieser kanal germane
german was noch immer ist auch natürlich
in der video beschreibung von ihnen
könnt ihr gern mal vorbeischauen
ich weiß nicht wie alt er ist aber ich
würde auf jeden fall chips der sich doch
ganz gut entwickelt wenn er weiter
youtube videos macht deswegen last auf
jeden fall mal ein abo da und wir kommen
jetzt an letzter stelle noch hier zu
jessy und lara und zwar haben die einen
vorstellungen das video hochgeladen ob
der rechtsextremist oder nicht weiß ich
nicht und die beiden sind gerade mal
zwölf jahre alt deswegen schauen wir
einfach mal kurz rein jetzt ins
vorstellungsvideo hey leute wir hoffen
unser erstes video wir durchgefallen
vergesst nicht ein like und einen kostet
aber dazu lassen würden uns freuen
bearbeitet mit viva videokamera iphone 5
s softbox menge von amazon
ja die haben auf jeden fall das ganze
equipment schon rein geballert ist
absolut okay am anfang mit einem iphone
aufzunehmen das iphone apps zum beispiel
jetzt ich glaube das ist fast besser als
diese kamera deswegen will ich da gar
nichts sagen dass wir video kenne ich ja
doch das kenne ich natürlich kann ich
das war schade dass das hier in der ecke
steht aber könnte man am anfang
vielleicht auch movie maker ausweichen
und soft rock ist natürlich auch ganz
wichtig und ja ich schau jetzt einfach
mal rein
ich dachte es ist ein vorstellungsvideo
[Musik]
ok kostenlos nein spaß das ist ja echt
gut zu sagen so viele youtuber sagen ja
auch am ende des videos
ihr könnt mich kostenlos abonnieren denk
mir dabei immer so eng dass man dich
kann man kostenlos abonnieren und andere
nicht oder was aber weil das so nicht
gesagt habe krieg die von mir auch noch
nach oben kostet gar nichts krass hey
cool ich werde euch verfolgen zu
kommentieren
[Musik]
ja okay was man sagen kann und gut es
ist jetzt nur ein vorstellungsvideo aber
das ganze geht halt nur eine minute
das ist schon extrem cool ich sag mal so
ich hab's halt auf den punkt gebracht
ihr habt gesagt wie heiß ich hab gesagt
was ihr macht und die hat gesagt das ist
cool werden wenn man dann noch oben geht
ist ja auch völlig in ordnung nur eine
minute ist halt schon kurz vielleicht
für die nächsten videos wenn es dann mal
so drei oder vier minuten geht ist
natürlich ganz wichtig von einem youtube
profi wie mir wenn das video auch mal
zehn minuten geht dann könnte jetzt oft
werbung einschalten wie ihr wollt könnt
ihr sogar 15 mal werbung schalten und
das spielt euch natürlich richtig gut in
die kassen
jetzt bin ich gespannt ja das war es mit
dem video das mit denen werbung war grad
natürlich nicht ernst gemeint ist das
wirklich so ist aber schaut auf jeden
fall bei allen kanälen vorbei wie gesagt
alles in der video beschreibung verlinkt
ist natürlich schön wenn man hier
ein paar abonnenten noch dazu bekommen
klasse nach oben dann wenn ihr noch so
einfach sehen wollt und schickt mir
gerne euren kanal auf instagram 240 alex
wie wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen
gibt's neues video hat rein